I am sitting next to the incredibly
good-looking cast of the upcoming
Transformers spin-off bus stop which is
being released this December how are you
guys thanks so much for being here very
good thank you thank you this movie is
so highly anticipated I am personally so
excited when I watch the trailer I
literally got chills when I heard the
late Bernie Mac's voice and it just
feels like such a coming-of-age movie
and I really got Iron Giant vibes is
that the tone of this movie is this
movie going to be like The Iron Giant
that I mean that is an aspect of it yes
I mean it is sort of modeled after those
classic Amblin spill burg in
coming-of-age tales of the 80s you know
things like et Iron Giant is in that
similar kind of vein you know that
experience that we go through as we're
transitioning from one phase in our life
to the next and it felt like the perfect
kind of setting and story to set this
origin story for bumblebee in that kind
of framework and Hailey's character
Charlie and bumblebee they meet each
other they're both these kind of broken
souls and over the course of this
adventure they heal each other it's a
really lovely and action-packed story oh
we're so excited for it since it's in
the 80s will we see bumblebee and a pair
of parachute pants or a Members Only
jacket maybe yeah you're gonna have to
see the movie well I'm not gonna say no
I'm not gonna say yes
well the 80s were a time where the
Transformers were basically I wouldn't
know but I've heard the best new friend
that any human could have some curious
to know George since we weren't around
in the 80s what is everyone's first
connection to the Transformers line
would be when they came up and literally
because you could get two toys for the
price of one toy so with four brothers
and a very busy household and everyone
trying to get what they could you with
transformers you could literally have
two toys for one toy so that's I can
vividly remember wanting transformers
for that reason right yeah for me was a
Transformers Armada which was I think
the second version of the TV show that
one didn't have bumblebee but I had hot
shot so when the movies came out I was
really like super confused but uh yeah
that was a fun time I remember that and
then the I think the McDonald's toys had
transformers for a bit so that was that
was my first time I'd always pick
boys happy I got the good toys it's
interesting because the Transformers
Universe has now been around for about
35 years so it's funny did you have
these different iterations people came
of age with these toys with these
characters and these swords at different
points for some people it's Michael's
films look for their first exposure
transformers for me and for John it was
the first time transformers were
launched in America and yeah I was a kid
when those toys came you know came onto
the market the animated series the comic
books came out and I absolutely loved
that I've never seen anything like it
and for us setting this film in that era
it allowed us to go back to that kind of
feel that kind of aesthetic and that
kind of vibe that you get from that
initial that if that initial launch of
the film why they were so wondrous and
so special right my parents always tried
me they always had the generic versions
it's certainly we won't name them oh yes
yeah a few Gobots you're ruining my life
we have the generic of everything I
still don't know what Froot Loops tastes
like you know they have grocery stores
that you can actually buy a box of Froot
Loops if you're so inclined I know I
should I should do that don't do it
don't do it I know right I feel
different flavored circles let's talk
about bumblebee that is the name of this
movie this is his origin story why do
you think bumblebee deserve the spin-off
over any other transformer from my
perspective yeah well I heard so much
from you to John you know cuz if
bumblebee is a fan favorite and why do
we love my movie so much in doing these
interviews I think traps explains it
extremely well and I can honestly say
that I feel the same way and he's the
captain of the ship so I feel like he
has to answer song I will say I agree
with him before he answers because I've
heard his answer before but he's a
hundred percent right well you know from
my perspective he's the most interesting
transformer in this sense that he's that
the 1 transformer who has the deepest
affinity for humanity who has the
greatest connection with people and I
was I thought that was really
interesting from his Oh from the first
time we see him in the animated series
he immediately attaches to this human
care
and it got anything why is that what can
we explore what is about him and who he
is he was before we got to know him and
who he is you know after this experience
that turns him into this kind of person
what is it about you I thought I thought
that was a fascinating thing to lean
into and this film does it's an origin
story explains who he was before we got
to know him and over the course of this
this journey he becomes the bumblebee
that we know lost this is his origin
story are we gonna get to hear his voice
I did you just ask a question because I
didn't hear anything so if you didn't
ask a question I can't answer it so I
never heard what sound makes you guys
think of the Transformers because for me
it's the voice of Optimus Prime that's a
good one are we gonna see optimism I can
confirm that Optimus does make is
something of an appearance a cameo of
sorts yes we have a lot of wonderful
little Easter eggs that are kind of laid
out throughout the film you don't need
to know anything about the Transformers
to enjoy it a lot of fun things for fans
like me and for fans of the series there
are a lot of fun aspects of the the
whole franchise that we weave into the
narrative
George I'm curious to know more about
your character who's your character have
a name and can we know more about he
does actually that's a very good
question his name is memo I'm new to the
neighborhood in this new origin story
I'm actually new to Haley's character
Charlie's neighborhood and I think that
she's a great person I'm buying for her
attention and my you know my my search
to get her attention kind of leads me
into this big bumblebee adventure and I
kind of got dragged along and things
ensue John I want to know more about
your character too because we know there
are three Decepticons so how does agent
burns kind of play into all of this
I can't tell you anything at this time
which is horrible so it makes this like
weird knock word cuz you're looking be
like are you really gonna not tell me
anything I've been sworn to secrecy
there's a group of people that travel
around with briefcases and cuff to their
arm and it's just agreements that I've
said not to say anything until it's time
to say something we have we have an
exposition of footage later on this
afternoon so if this were later on in
the space-time continuum then you could
talk to maybe a bit more but until then
Instagram account
Travis is obviously first live action
without Michael Bay oh yeah first live
action without Michael Bay so I needed
to know who was more of a diva on set
John Cena Bobby well considering the
fact that bumblebee was never on set he
actually is a CG animated character
magic I guess it would have to be John
know I will take that claim I was
definitely more of a diva on set this
was it fun for you to play a villain
I can't confirm nor deny that I am
playing neither a villain nor hero
I don't even know if I have a part in
this picture I just wandered into this
video all right well thank you guys for
tuning in - you'll have to wait to see
the movie to find out all the answers to
these questions but seriously thank you
guys so much we are so excited for this
movie bumblebee first spin-off of
transformer coming out this December
thanks guys I'm sitting next to the
beautiful Hailee Steinfeld know it's the
first female lead in the first
transformers spin-off bumblebee set to
release this December Hayley how does
that feel to be the first female lead of
a Transformers movie well wouldn't I
hear it out loud like that it's pretty
insane I feel very fortunate to have
been given the opportunity to play this
role of this character Charlie Watson in
bumblebee she she really she's really a
special character she's got a lot to say
and and unique ways of saying it so I'm
excited for people to meet her can you
tell us more about Charlie aside from
what is she more of like a tomboy yeah
she's definitely definitely more of a
tomboy she really is your typical sort
of misunderstood teenager and there's
this freedom that she absolutely craves
and basically finds her way into that
and that's that's through a car and then
obviously that car turns into something
other than a car and there's this
budding friendship and journey within
all of that so she plays a mechanic so
how are you with cars in real life how
are your driving skills well I will say
my my brother is a mechanic in a racecar
driver so I was like how do I put this
lightly but no that's what he does so I
he was on set with me when I made this
movie and I constantly was calling him
and to set to help me with lines and
make sure that he could explain and
Britt there was at one point he was like
printing out like I mean definitions and
graphs and outlines of cars and
everything to explain to me what
everything was so he he was my little
cheat sheet on this movie so it sounds
like the best brother ever yep do you
have a love interest in this film um
that part I'm not going to tell you
there
tons of emotion though and love and I
mean heartfelt everything in this movie
there are relationships there are
conflicts and inner obstacles and outer
obstacles with Charlie and her friends
and her family and people that she likes
and and and stuff like that but um that
part you're gonna have to wait and see
I'm so excited because it seems like
there's way more emotion in this movie
than what we're used to how is this
movie stylistically different from the
transformer movies we've seen in the
past
well you said it perfectly just and it
has it has a lot of emotion it's it's
you know it's an origin story and it's
very character-driven and storyline
driven and yeah I mean it all stems
around this this girl and and who she is
in her family and and her way of finding
who she is in life right when we think
Transformers movies we think huge epic
scale action scenes are we gonna get
that in this absolutely absolutely um
Transformers fans will definitely get
their their taste of that of what the
Transformers films are known for so
there is definitely a bit of action I
was able to partake in some of it which
was exciting
and the whole the whole shoot was really
I mean everyday you kind of never really
knew what was gonna happen and filming
something like this where I mean you
want to say 90% of the film is in is in
special effects it's like I can't wait
to see the final product of this because
it'll be as if you know I don't know the
story necessarily in a way because it's
kind of like I can't wait to see what
they put in around me I hope what I
imagined was somewhat correct right well
this movie obviously takes place in the
80s and we weren't around then so how
are you able to connect to the era um
well first of all our director Travis
Knight he was himself a child of the 80s
so he was able to break down the
specifics for us but also just really
being able to immerse myself in that in
that era I find it pretty fascinating
myself in terms of the style and the
muse
so I had a great time you know going
back to that but my character Charlie we
it was it was one of my favorite parts
in developing her was you know with the
the hair and the makeup in the wardrobe
Ron our vision boards basically
consisted of Debbie Harry Madonna and I
mean just iconic women of the 80s and I
loved being able to like go on the
trailer everyday and see them and have
that be the sort of inspiration
stylistically for this character you're
obviously an incredible singer do you
have any music in the movie my lips are
sealed on that um the music obviously
plays a huge role in this movie so I I'm
hoping you know the movies in
post-production right now so everything
is kind of in its final stages of coming
together so if there's an opportunity to
to be involved in that sense then
absolutely I'd love to so my favorite
part of the trailer was at the very end
when Charlie basically Rick rolls
bumblebee okay do you know what
rickrolling
I don't but I was gonna act like I did I
mention it cuz I really have no idea
it's when you click on a link on the
internet and you think it's gonna be one
thing but really it's that song by Rick
Astley not gonna give you up right so
you basically Rick Rolled bumblebee hey
I'm gonna use that like that are there
any transformers that you can tease that
maybe in this movie that we might see oh
well there are there are we learned that
Optimus is makes a little cami on the
movies sure there are a couple little
cameos here and there that I think
people will be really excited about and
yes optimises is in there so um yeah I
mean I guess love to wait and see all
right well we are so excited
Hayley thank you so much for stopping by
I think you wait to watch this movie
you look amazing thanks for tuning in a
bumblebee is set to release this
December 2018
[Music]